für mich geht es heute auf die gamescom
und dann komme ich schneller als je
zuvor denn ich fliege mit diesem
raumschiff commander aktiviere wab 4
[Musik]
mein letzter stand ist der c64 kennt ihr
commodore ist seitdem viel passiert oder
du kannst nur die n64 ganze vielleicht
1928 das ist das nachfolgemodell ist ein
128-bit in oder worum gehts ja warum
heißt das und gedacht das war's denke
bist du heute auch gegen angela merkel
da nein natürlich nicht
wenn angela gezogen würde was für spiele
während call of duty wahrscheinlich ein
schöner ego-shooter die brutale norma
die brutale macht ja die voll drauf wenn
angela merkel einen charakter wäre es
einem spiel wer wäre sie
das ist schwierig
[Musik]
was ist sie so für ein typ wenn man sich
so in der fantasy-welt jetzt mal
umschaut
ich bin leider kein wow zocker solche
leute aber ich würde sagen ein problem
also bei mir muss sich nicht
entschuldigen ok paladin könnte ich mir
gut vorstellen oder hex hex hex umher
also jetzt ist action in dem sinne aber
so wie denn sonst ja der charakter
wechseln wollte
ich habe jetzt an den anderen gedacht
als ich zugestimmt habe aber könnte das
angela merkel spielen könnte sich damit
identifizieren dann ja er ist ein
wissenschaftler
frau merkel hat beziehungsweise doktor
merkel hat ja einen doktortitel also
denke ich mal wird damit es würde passen
weil winston hat auch ist auch ein
wissenschaftler also vom charakter her
würde diensten doch zu
merkel passen erst sogar merkel mit
einem affen verglichen
es ist ein genetisch modifizierte harfe
der intelligent
[Musik]
merkel will kommen im neuland jetzt geht
sie wahrscheinlich zu den russischen
ständen um sich zu informieren wie die
bundestagswahl ausgehen wird glaubst du
angela merkels ob privat nein definitiv
nicht brauchen nicht ich glaube ja den
ganzen tag die raute vom spieler anstatt
dass irgendwas gesagt oder kannst du
nicht aus mit diesen waffen
ich kenne mich ein bisschen aus glaubst
du die bundeswehr besser aufgestellt und
diesen waffen mit sicherheit nur etwas
was können die denn jetzt zum beispiel
ich weiß auch dass das eine ist ein
raketenwerfer
das ist wahrscheinlich ein automatik
wäre hätten ganze ist natürlich bitter
dass sie funktionieren nicht sagen wir
es so ich stehe hier bei call of duty
world water aber diesmal gewinnen war
natürlich immer dann bin ich auch dabei
[Musik]
kann die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
überhaupt mit modernen ballerspielen
konkurrieren ja teilweise schon ehrlich
ja alle spieler haben einen großen
vorteil man hat meistens drei leben dass
man mal nicht muss retten ich kenne ich
ganz genau deswegen muss ich retten
ehrlich aber ich habe mit rosa von der
langen sporn nicht gesagt ist ungefähr
die bundesprüfstelle ist ja dafür da um
gefahren für jugendliche abzuwenden
jetzt habe ich mit ein paar jugendlichen
gesprochen bedroht fühlen die sich
eigentlich nur durch sie ihr geld da ist
die spaßverderber auf jeden fall
deswegen sind wir auch so alleine hier
am stand müssen wir schon geschenken
locken die auch keiner haben will ja
nicht mal ich das war die gamescom 2017
krasse spiele und ein ungewöhnlicher
schlag menschen deshalb freue ich mich
jetzt auf einen ganz normalen doppelkopf
abend mit meinen beiden kumpels
süß
[Musik]